hey youtubers is Charlie so big news we
learned that cyborg is going to be in
the flash movie now obviously Justice
League and Wonder Woman are coming up
next so flash is still a little ways off
but there's gonna be a breakdown of
what's going on and some of the stuff
we'll probably see in that movie I'm
gonna go ahead and call this the STAR
Labs movie because even though it's the
flash movie it's largely taking place in
and around what's going on with STAR
Labs the tech based characters cyborg
who was basically like the Robocop of
the DC universe if you've never watched
any of the animated Justice League
movies that deal with his backstory like
the Justice League war film is kind of
like a CliffsNotes for his backstory
it's okay like you don't have to read
the comics but it is a lot of fun though
you know the Robocop eighties Robocop
I'm not talking about the modern Robocop
is a more darker spin on the idea of
where man stops and where machine begins
how does he deal with being more machine
than man because that that is really
what's going on with the cyborg
character and while all the solo movies
like the first solo movie that each of
these characters gets will deal with
their backstory you're gonna get shades
of that when you see cyborg for the
first time at Justice League so just to
back it up a little bit what do we know
about the flash most of you guys have at
least seen a little bit of the flash TV
show if you're not big fans of it maybe
if you've read the comics you have an
idea for Barry Allen's backstory I think
we'll find out what Barry Allen's been
doing this whole time how long he's had
his powers when Justice League comes
along then during the flash movie like
you'll actually go back and you'll see a
bunch of that and you'll meet most of
the flash specific characters people in
Central City Keystone City stuff from
the comics it just depends on how much
they want to do from the comics in how
much this story is going to be
completely new because there's so much
darkside new god stuff going on I'm
actually wondering because cyborg is
kind of like an overlap character he's
basically a Justice League hero that got
his powers via mother box which is a
device that comes from Jack Kirby's
fourth world New Gods Darkseid and the
forces of apocalypse so it's entirely
possible that we'll see like the reverse
flash during the flash movie they might
choose to just deal with what's going on
in Justice League the aftermath of that
and villains the poor out of that but
one of the really fun things though is
that Amanda Waller said that metahumans
are popping up everywhere
that kind of happened on the flash TV
show that was the jumping off point for
season 1 so when you're wondering what
the plot of the flash movie is going to
be about what I'm hoping is is that they
largely keep it earth-based they explore
the big overarching plot the idea of
metahumans aliens from outer space
Kryptonian technology mother boxes from
a scientific perspective like is there
some way that we can repurpose all this
stuff for good and then also dealing
with a lot of the earth-based stuff
that's going on that you saw on Suicide
Squad metahumans popping up everywhere
that means classic flash rogue so you're
like you can't do the flash movie
without doing classic deep cuts from the
flash comics so of course even if
they're not like really big characters I
think we'll see all the stuff that you
saw in the flash TV show like we'll see
the reverse flash we'll learn about
eobard thawne Gorilla Grodd will learn
how Barry Allen was able to travel into
Bruce's dream in the past because this
is in the future like it's a future
version of the flash to warm Bruce to
find Lois Lane she is the key because he
you know he was basically telling Bruce
giving him the idea for Justice League
so if you're wondering with that crazy
nightmare that Batman had with the Omega
symbol in the evil version of Superman
was all about it was basically a
combination of what the flash was
telling him about this danger that's
coming to earth in a vision of what
would happen were he unsuccessful so
time-travel is a big concept when it
comes to the flash you've been watching
the flash TV show you know all about how
Barry derps he's gone back in time
several times since the show has started
not all of them on purpose so we'll
probably see some of that in the flash
movie but what I'm really hoping like
here's the big question is is like who's
gonna be the biggest villain of the
flash movie what I'm hoping is is
because they have cyborg and he's gonna
be kind of like a crossover character
with the new gods I'm hoping they do a
new gods big bad for the flash and that
would be the black racer and I know a
lot of you guys are like well hey you
know how come the villain always has to
have the exact same powers is the hero
that's not the case they could totally
go with a different new gods villain
because the tone of the flash is a
little more jokey a little bit funnier
they could totally do Kalibak that would
be crazy because he's just like big
hulking gorilla grodd size figure who
just kind of like a big dumb animal but
his super powerful
is nothing like Grodd in that effect
Grodd is like a super smart ape Kalibak
is like a really dumb ape that would
actually be good if they wanted to go a
little off-book but I think they're
gonna play it safe so I'm expecting some
blend of classic flash villain with new
gods stuff it'll largely be the
day-to-day of the Barry Allen flash like
we're just getting brief glimpses of him
and all this Justice League footage so
what like we'll get to spend an extended
amount of time get to meet iris West
like they've already cast the iris West
character and we've already met cyborgs
father who is a professor at STAR Labs
who's in this Batman V Superman sequence
where we actually see cyborg become
cyborg when the mother box fuses with
them I don't know how big STAR Labs is
gonna be in this universe but presumably
that's where they are when cyborg is
becoming cyborg so let me know in the
comments who do you want them to use for
the big bad in the flash movie do you
want it to be a flash villain from the
comics like the reverse flash or do you
want it to be one of the new gods like
the black racer or a Kalibak or someone
that doesn't have any powers that look
anything like the Flash's I just feel
like if they're gonna try and do the
biggest thing they could possibly do
having the flash go up against death
itself would probably be a pretty
interesting idea it just depends on how
they tackle it because I think the tone
of the film is going to be a lot lighter
than what you've seen before like it's
not gonna be in the tone of a Batman
movie Batman movies are really dark
heavy drama with moments of comedy the
flash is gonna be like the opposite of
that but I do really like the idea of
them doing a cyborg movie in the tone of
Robocop
so when related flash news you guys are
get really excited about this one of the
producers of the TV show was talking
about savat are who is that black flash
that we've seen all the pictures of and
the guy that we see in the trailer so
I'll do a video for that on Thursday
they also drop the first official poster
for spider-man homecoming you know
friendly neighborhood hat tip so I'll
probably do a spider-man homecoming
video soon there is a new round of the
giveaway that starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll just remind
everyone when I post that flash season 3
video so get hype force avatar deep cut
from the Wally West comics boy you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn more about the flash season 3
and you can click here to learn about
the mystery DC
the James gun was offered after
guardians of the galaxy he was actually
offered a DC movie so thank you so much
for watching everybody looks at five
I'll see you guys tonight